you've been you've been funny in so many
different movies but you must have been
surprised at this american pie
success like you know did you have any
idea when you were doing that movie that
was gonna become this phenomenon no i
got
i think my take-home pay was 700 bucks
for that right and you just thought okay
i'm going to do this and then move on to
the next project and that's a movie that
i mean it's huge here in this country
but i i think it's even internationally
huge is it it's huge i mean you know i
don't know about ever you know i haven't
been all over the world but i you know
in london
you know i was just there recently and
i had no idea that american pie was such
a huge movie over there and i was
yeah i was walking by a pub and i guess
they let all the little boys out of
school and then they go to the pubs
all these eleven-year-old boys
boys are at the pubs you know in their
little jackets and their little ties and
i walked by and you know i got like 100
feet down the street and then i hear
stiffness mom
all of them in unison
they're so cute the way they say it cute
boy hello it's stifler's mom it is
and they all started dancing like
chimney sweeps i hope yes they did they
were really incredible
but i mean i got recognized more there
for american pie than i i've ever been
here i mean really it was like stopping
every two seconds but i gotta say when i
came out in the in the monologue it's
sometimes hard to hear through the
laughs but um
but anyway uh
when i was
when i when i was out and i and i
mentioned that you were that you were on
the show uh and i was like you know
stifler's mom is here there's this whole
section of boys over there that we've
now restrained but uh people really
people really get excited about this do
you find that that young guys kind of
think that you know that you're gonna be
this sort of racy woman just because of
the role
yes i know they're hoping that yeah yeah
that maybe you're that same person maybe
i'm yeah i mean you get a lot of credit
you know right when you do a movie you
get credit for things that you know the
movie says you're something then
you know right then people just think oh
okay well it's a given that this woman
is incredibly sexual and right yeah
right i mean yeah i was really lucky i'm
glad there weren't more girls
auditioning for that part i never would
have gotten it
[Laughter]
now you play
you're great some people might think
it's easy i actually think one of the
hardest things to do is is to
play that i would i'd imagine play that
dumb blonde
roll it's very difficult and you do it
really
well do you ever
yeah thank you a little too well frankly
no uh you you play it so well do you
ever use that kind of character in real
life to your advantage like ever become
the dumb blonde just to get yourself out
of a situation me and everywhere yeah no
i the only time i've where it's really
worked is you know i you know i grew up
in boston and which part of boston did
you grow up in norwell
and
a little town there but you know in
boston if you're pulled over by the cops
and you're a girl and you have all your
teeth you can actually
you can actually like talk them out of
the ticket right right but in la there's
so many beautiful girls and supermodels
and all these so
you know no matter what they pull you
over for you usually
get the ticket the only time i didn't
get the ticket was i try i've always
tried to like be funny and stuff like
that never gets me out of it but this
one time this cop pulled me over and he
was like you know you have no plates on
your car and you're driving do you have
registration i was like no i don't he
goes uh do you know what that means to
have you have no plates on your car and
i was like
you're kidding
[Laughter]
and then he went on and on and on right
everything he said i would just go no
you're kidding okay yeah and that was
the only time i didn't get the ticket
that was the only time the guy like my
father was gonna get the ticket he went
and got in his squad car and then he
drove away well
and i think it was like i think he felt
so bad that i had to live my life like
that
i can't
i gotta ask you driving a car without
plates by the way that's pretty bad no i
know
hey you gotta do what you gotta do
you've been struggling actors for years
i had no plates for years well let's
talk about that you
you just drive around you just write on
with lipstick you just wrote some
numbers on the back of your car
k3 blah blah blah let's go
um when you were struggling out there uh
you uh well you worked in a restaurant
didn't you did you work in a restaurant
here in new york yes canis delts 19th
and park and who very long time another
famous person worked there too yes
sandra bullock was the hostess
and i was the cocktail waitress
and uh
well what happened was i stopped really
showing up for all my shifts i would
show up for maybe like i like i had like
five shifts and i would show up for
three of them
but in those days i was in my 20s and i
was just a mess and um
i like to go out to night clubs and
things and um
so i stopped uh i like the guys the
owner wouldn't fire me and so eventually
one day sandra
got my cocktail my friday and saturday
night shifts
and that's when i had to quit quit i was
so mad sandra got the shifts
but i wasn't showing up i wasn't trying
to get a job but but it was for years of
not showing up for the for the for a lot
of the shifts
and um
and you know and you know i mean i you
know i we had to wear these like white
jackets and like mine was all stained in
the back
like i had like who knows what it was on
the back of my jacket god
you sound like the worst
cocktail waitress ever but they would
never fire me and so you know i i just
so how can you i've been fired like the
first month and i got like five years
out of the deal yeah so any big celebs
ever come by like to to eat dinner or
have it um yes uh o.j simpson told me he
was going to get me my sag card oh yeah
yes he did did he seem like a nice guy
well yeah
but not that nice he didn't give me my
sag card
you weren't there half the time
he probably came back with it and you
weren't there
[Applause]
where'd she go oh i don't know where i
was driving around in a beverly
hillbilly's car with no
license plate on it
uh legally blonde two red white and
blonde uh is in
theaters now jennifer thanks so much for
coming thanks for having me
josh kelly coming up to take a break
we'll be right back